We can connect the subject's thinking
to several topics we have already
covered in this class.
You may recall that
early on in this course,
we used frames to understand
stories of this kind.
Now this story is actually capturing
some information about a system.
In this political system, there is
a country with people and a president.
It also had geological faults as
a result of which earthquakes occur
that killed some people.
So the components, the complex
relationships between these components,
the complex processes that emerge out of
this interaction between the components.
Scripts, too,
are related to system thinking.
Dining at a restaurant
is a complex system.
Once again, there are a number of
components, relationships, interactions,
processes, functions.
A script is a knowledge for presentation
that allows us to capture knowledge
of a stereotypical dining
experience at a restaurant.
When we discussed diagnosis,
at that time we talked about systems
thinking a little bit more explicitly.
To begin with, we said that diagnosis
is identification of a fault
responsible for a malfunctioning system.
Diagnosis begins with the observed
data about some system what are its
expectations of the behavior
expected of it.
The diagnostic paths takes the data and
matches it to hypotheses of a fault
responsible for that behavior.
What makes a diagnostic task so hard,
again, is that there are a large number
of components that interact with each
other, and it is a complex behavior that
emerges out of the interaction
between these components.
Just think of program debugging.
Program debugging is hard because there
are a large number of lines in the code,
and these lines in the code
interact with each other, and very
complex behaviors, output behaviors,
emerge because of those interactions.
>> So another good example of how
diagnosis is a case of systems thinking
is if we look at ecological systems.
Recently there's been a massive drop in
the population of bees around the world.
That's our data.
As it turns out, the cause for this drop
in bee population is the presence of
a poisonous substance in insecticides
used in the past several years.
However, we can't see the process of
bees getting poisoned by this chemical.
All we can do is infer it based on
higher level interactions of seeing
the bee populations drop and
seeing a rise in this chemical.
So, in this way, there's multiple
levels of abstraction in this process.
There's the visible bee population,
there's the visible use of pesticide,
but
there's also an invisible layer where
the pesticide actually poisons the bees.
So, we have to discern the interaction
between these multiple levels.
>> In any complex system there will
be many levels of abstraction,
some invisible, some visible.
The human eye, or human senses more
generally, can see only some of these
levels of abstraction,
the visible levels of abstraction.
System thinking helps us
understand the invisible levels.